been 10 days now since Nicola went
missing
I have two little girls who miss their
mummy desperately and we need a back
it's been such a tough time for the
girls especially but also for me all of
Nikki's family and friends as well as a
wider Community I want to thank them for
their love and support
we also really grateful to Peter and his
team from SGI for coming up and helping
support the work of Lancashire police as
they continue their investigation
their support is amazing if anyone has
any information which could help find
Nikki I urge them please to get in touch
with the police
help us provide the answers that we all
so badly need
we have to find a safe and well
I can't put those girls to bed again
tonight
with no answers it's
yeah
thank you